[Music]  this christmas  be prepared hang on to your  seats critics are calling it  sensational okay okay let's try that  again  what is up my name's samuel leeds love  me or hate me i make a lot of money in  property and i'm back this year  2020 helping more people become  financially free  in the eviction and i'm back too after  covert has dried up pretty much  all voice over work last year's eviction  was absolutely thrilling with anthony  bagging the 20 000 pound top prize and  this year the whole show is being shaken  up samuel leeds style  with more action what you've been doing  for the last five days on everybody else  and more devastating rejection than  you've ever seen on youtube before  you're a victim you're a victim you're a  victim join us on boxing day 2020  to watch a whole bunch of new candidates  ride the thrills and spills of property  subscribe to the samuel leeds channel  now and we'll see you on december 26th  for brand new the eviction